and many times when you go out and the
children M theyum and that reminds me
that once i' had gone to meet a very big
businessman a top businessman in Bombay
very big businessman and when I met him
I had my son with me that time he was in
the second standard and the businessman
was smoking so my son said
Uncle smoking is Haram finish I would
think 10 times you know you know to say
directly we have to know see for the
situation and we see whether what is the
right time they should not feel hurt Etc
we'll think 10 times how to say when to
say what to say and the young child said
and the person put off his cigarette
immediately
easy so mashallah we should see to it
that we should have vision of how do we
want our children and what they should
become we have a concept that on average
when we have four divisions if 100
students pass out in a year from month
School 50% may go in the mainstream may
become doctors Engineers lawyers but
when they become doctors there'll be
true Muslim doctors having knowledge of
Islam true Muslim Engineers true Muslim
businessman 50% may go in the Islamic
field may become M mu may take up
teaching Islamic teaching alhamdulillah
so in this way can we change the Next
Generation we can't keep on cribbing
about what's happening we should make a
beginning and in this way mashallah the
main success that I feel of the school
is that our interviews are very strict
the interviews we conduct are so strict
that the rules that we started the rules
are unheard of we broke most of the
conventional pattern normally for the
students they have got three interviews
the child and even the parents are
interviewed the father and the mother
they have to undergo two interviews of
average of one and a half hour each and
the final interview is taken by me and
alhamdulillah in the second year we had
800 applications
75 seats 800 applications so most of the
years we have 10 times more number of
application than the number of seats and
let me tell you our school is one of the
most expensive schools in
mumbay the fees is we 25,000 rupees a
month which is very expensive average
fees in Bombay is 10050 rupees the good
Convent schools they charge 1,000 rupees
1 and half th000 rupees as 25,000
that is $600 us though not there other
schools which are much expensive but
Islamic school mashallah so not that it
is cheap but yet no poor person can say
that I did not get admission because I
did not have money we have 25%
scholarship
Kota the 25% of the seats even if the
person does not pay a single rupe a
month he can get admission so 25% of the
seats have been reserved for poor
children so in our school we have
mashallah parents who are earning more
than a CR p a month they may be
millionaires there are they be earning
million pounds they earn there are some
students whose parents earn 3,000
rupees but when we give scholarship we
transfer that amount of fees into the
current account when they get the money
they come and pay full fees to the
cashier so even the cashier does not
know who the scholarship child it's only
the management me my wife who the
principal and a few others who know who
are scholarship children so even the
teachers don't know who the scholarship
child so we maintain that secrecy so we
transfer the money in the account they
come and pay full fees so even the
Casher does not know so that we have a
proper system and equality while
teaching when we have the formal
education mathematics History Science
geography we see to it that in this when
we teach we incorporate 25% Islam in it
for example when we teach science we
talk about The Big Bang Theory that a
few decades earlier the scientist have
discovered how did our universe come
into existence first there was a primary
nebula then there was a secondary
separation which gave life to galaxies
the Stars the planets and the earth on
which we live then we say this is
mentioned in the Quran 1400 years ago
inah chapter number
21 verse number
30 do not the unbeliever
see that the heavens and the Earth were
join together and we cloth the aund now
this what the scientists have discovered
recently the Quran mentions 1400 years
ago about the Big Bang so in this way
the child comes closer to Allah subhana
wa ta'ala at the same time he's being
educated about
science we tell them that the first
person who described the blood
circulation it was
Naf later on William Havi made it famous
to the Western
World we even teach them Davin the
unlike the other school I realize that
in some Western countries a child goes
to the normal convent school government
School in the evening he goes to evening
madrasas so in the morning he's taught
that the human beings have been created
from monkey and the evening he's told
that the first man is Adam Alam in the
morning he Tau that RBA is very good
interest you can become a great
businessman wealthy person in the
evening he Tau RBA interest is Haram so
there dichotomy there'll be confusion in
the mind of the children that does not
mean don't send your children to madrasa
mad are doing good work alhamdulillah
they should continue better send them
than don't send don't get me wrong the
Mad are very good mashallah I'm for it
I'm not against it but we have to keep
on improving the standards so whatever
doing mashallah they're doing a good
work when I go to madasa I tell them
that you incorporate English there you
incorporate the for
subjects so when there is a different
teaching in the morning and the evening
the child is
confused so when we teach science we see
to it that we incorporate and tell them
even quranic verses lat to that Quran
speaks about water cycle about geography
salt and Sweet Water Quran speaks about
geology that mountain have got roots and
many thing which is not mentioned in the
textbook the teachers they are
trained they trained how to
teach and in this way out of the normal
formal education 25% Islam is even
Incorporated when we teach the
mathematics science history geography
Etc we have taken the normal syllabus
igcs following that syllabus and even
incorporating the Islamic Studies both
in Arabic and English so that when the
child appears he appears for the normal
examination that is the central board
examination after he passes that he can
take up medicine take up
engineering or become a lawyer or a
businessman or come to the mainstream of
Islamic Studies no problem he has this
choice and what we are doing that we are
in contact mallah with those people who
are experts in the world as Allah says
in the Quran in chapter number 16 ver 43
and chapter number 21 verse number
7 that if you don't know as the person
knowledgeable so we are in touch with
the knowledgeable people from different
parts of the world we in touch with the
Lo Experts of Madina city of Etc we in
touch so that whatever things that we
want to put
it into practice in our school we
consult with the experts but we are
doing many things which are
unconventional many people told me that
Z it's not possible you can't have two
steam at the same time it's not possible
I tell them at least make Dua at least
make Dua inshallah so what we want to do
we want to give a sample role model to
the umah that it's possible though many
people majority said it's not possible
but alhamdulillah alhamdulillah
if you meet the parents and if you see
the annual day CD of a program then
you'll come to know alhamdulillah that
what is the level of education mashallah
so as I was telling the main thing is
the interview when we interview the
parents we are very strict we are very
careful that we see to it that the
parents have the same thinking as the
management and we are very strict in the
first year when we started the school we
had a clause compulsory that the mothers
should do
hijab more than 50% of the mothers in
the first year of our school they were
not doing hijab but within one month's
time mashallah all of them had to do
hijab now when they want to admit their
child they do field work okay if you
want to get admission to Islam
International School we have to do hijab
so before coming to the interview they
hijab they're trained because they want
admission in our school so they do a
survey what is the requirement of the
school we have got mashallah millionaire
parents who are businessman who are
business tycoons when they come for the
interview we ask them how many times do
you offer Salah so they tell us
J so we tell them brother then don't
admit your child in the school go and
put him in a convent school he says why
because we will teach your child it's
mentioned in say Muslim the difference
between IM and isah maybe your child
after 3 four years will call you a cfir
therefore don't put him in a school put
them in a convent school they said no we
want admission here we will offer Salah
we will offer five times Salah then they
give it in
writing so it's compulsory
that 100% of the parents they give in
writing that they will offer Salah five
times believe me we did not know that we
could actually pressurize the parents or
blackmail them when the Christian
missionaries are blackmailing our Muslim
children our Muslim parents in Bombay
they are paying £5,000 £10,000 to get
admission and after paying that money
as bribe every day our children are
doing shik they saying Jesus Christ
peace be upon Him is God so when the
Christian missionaries can force them to
do sh why can't we force to do something
with his far and believe me we have been
very
successful we know it is not allowed by
this government and that government but
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah so mashallah
even the
multi-millionaire he wait for the
interview we tell him the interview will
take time be prepared at at least four
five hours and you'll be interviewed for
about 1 and a half to two hours and
mashallah we have a big questionnaire
and we explain to them the concept of
the school and we tell them that the
satellite television is a big shaitan so
the cable TV satellite TV should not be
in your house TV is not Haram but the
cable TV the satellite TV is a big Shan
and normally we find that we know that
in the western statistics the average in
America a child sits in front of the TV
for approximately 7 hours on average
more time than he spends in school even
in India they spend several hours and
what happened you know when we say that
if you want admission you remove the
cable TV and mashallah they have to do
it otherwise no admission so because
they want they may not be practicing
Muslims but they have that jba they have
the IM they want to put in the school
and now it has become a status oh my son
got admission into IIs status
alhamdulillah Allah has given us that
status so to get admission means it's
the status I got admission in Islamic
International School I passed the
interview so then we realized that once
the C TV is out and it's compulsory that
the parents the mother should attend
every week of Islamic lectures
compulsory at least once father twice a
month compulsory if you don't have time
then no
admission so even the parents are being
ingrained it's a package we are not only
training the students we are even
training the parents we don't want that
we trained the child and after 13 years
the father says okay now go and do
business okay start giving bribe Etc so
we want to seat we we don't want to pour
water or drugs back chances are there
50% we will lose our children because
finally the parents control them so we
even change the
parents and if we know that the business
the parent is doing is not good we'll
tell you there are some people who have
got businesses maybe they're working in
bank I we tell them working in bank is
Haram Maybe maybe your child once after
four five years he will cause you
trouble so see to to change your job
fast so knowingly very well yet they
want to put their children in our
school and the point to be noted here is
that after a few months then the husband
comes and tells us you know my wife she
has stopped watching TV now she gives me
more time so even the Family Life
improves we have got stipulated
conditions before admission that minimum
20 minutes every day they should be a
family reading of the Quran along with
translation every day compulsory the
father should attend twice a month our
lectures in which we talk about Islam
the mothers once a week so in this way
mashallah even the environment becomes
Islamic then besides the parents even
the other siblings come even the
grandparents come so it is rather
changing the society and we found that
when we visited the Western school I'd
gone to South Africa and I'd gone to one
of the best schools in South Africa
about 6 years back I don't want to name
the school the principal of the school
told me that brother Zakir we are at the
mercy of the parents we have to force
them to come and take admission though
our fees is half than the other private
schools but then they blackmail us if
you tell us too many things then we'll
go to the government school we'll go to
the white school and he told me our
students in the eth standard ninth
standard girls one evening we went to a
hotel and we found our girls wearing
mini skirts and shorts and dancing
imagine one of the best schools in South
Africa and the parents were called the
parents are
blackmailing if we get two STS we'll
take out our children from here here in
our school we blackmail the parents but
natural for the sake of Allah subhana
tala anyway the school is not a business
so what fees we take we are spending
from our own pocket so it's not a
business please don't get me wrong the
school irf always does everything free
the school is the first thing we're
charging money but even those who are
paying full fees we are subsidizing the
fees so in this way mashallah we want to
create a new
society and what we feel that most of
the organization that start it's a one
man show after the person goes away the
whole thing goes down most of the Muslim
organization you see it's a one man show
that person goes away the organization
falls down so we see to it that we
require backups at present m in a
foundation Islam Foundation we have more
than 15 speakers M besides myself and
some of them travel in different parts
of the world they have been to UK
Singapore Hong Kong Malaysia South
Africa sever places mashallah and these
children mashallah they are our future
generation and if you see the annual day
that we have in the annual day when we
have skits normally most of the other
schools they have fancy days where a
person maybe he may dress up like
Michael Jackson or may dress up like
maybe Sunil gasar or whatever it is here
in our concert mashallah one person
becomes he imitates sh
sudesh one like sh Ahmed dad you know in
this way mashallah we find that the role
models of our children the present age
role models for our children they are
not these pop stars and pop singers and
film actors they are like shik sudesh
like Sheik Ahmed dad brother B Phillips
so here we find that we should ingrain
in our children children that what
should they become when they grow up and
mashah if you see that these children
they are taught public speaking right
from Junior kg from the age of four they
taught to stand in front of the
microphone and they are taught how to
speak on the microphone most of our
speakers I'm sorry to say they don't
know public speaking techniques what
should be the distance from the mic how
is the modulation how it should go up
how it should come down the gestures the
I to ey contact see when a person gives
gives a speech on the stage the matter
he speaks carries only 7% marks how much
7% 93% is presentation skills how do you
modulate your gestures your ey to ey
contact that's the reason today actually
I'm handicapped the sound system is not
good it is like you're sending a warrior
to a battlefield without weapons we
should be trained that how we should be
able to dawa the children right from the
age of four they trained public speaking
in English as well as Arabic so we want
that a future generation that they
should be trained alhamdulillah so this
was a vision with which we started the
school not knowing whether we' be
successful or not alhamdulillah Allah
subhana wa ta'ala has been so much
helpful and grateful that we got
application from different parts of the
world from different cities in India we
have application to start the school in
Saudi Arabia in UAE in Yemen in UK in
USA several application so far we have
only started one more branch in
chenai and our criteria are very strict
mallah so inshallah we feel that every
few years we'll open one school so that
it will be role model for the
others one thing we have to realize that
for Success we have to follow the
guidance of the Quran and the sayth and
always we have to be professional as
Allah says in the Quran in Sur n 16:43
and Sur Amia chapter number 21 verse
number 7
if you don't know ask the person who's
knowledgeable ask the person who
possesses the message we as a policy in
our organization Islam Research
Foundation though we are a very small
organization was started 15 years
back alhamdulillah we had only one
employee now we have more than 400
employees full-time paid
employees we always believe that we
should be professional and all the
people that we employ mashallah we have
a policy that whatever they're
drawing in Bombay if they join
organization we give them more we don't
believe that if you getting 20,000
rupees so come here for 50% 10,000 rupes
for Allah sake if you're 20,000 rupes
we'll give you 25,000 if you're 30 we'll
give you 35 if you're giving 50 we'll
give you 60 but then you
work you strive in the way of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala I don't want the
parent phoning me up the doctor asking I
give a Islamic lecture and now my son is
earning half if I give him more even the
parents are with me even in our school
Islamic International School that as far
as the teachers we have got strict
conditions even for the teachers and
initially I'm a nightmare even for the
parents I'm a nightmare R for the
teachers we have so many rules and
regulations someone called us the
alqaeda
school Kaa means we have too many rules
and regulations and our teachers
mashallah on an average we interviewed
about 2 and a half th000 teachers and
selected less than 25 or
0.1% the selection similarly for our kis
the kis we selected we interviewed in
different parts of India lakau nadwa
various parts Surat our crew went and
there too we interviewed more than 4,000
kuras and now we have 40 car we have so
a selection procedure it is very strict
less than 1% of the people we
interview we take them as our staff and
once we take the staff the staff we pay
them more than what they get outside we
give an open a in the newspapers that if
selected we will pay you more than what
you're drawing they says like that if
selected in our school we will pay you
more than what you're
drawing irrespective what you're earning
in any convent school if you're teaching
we keep only Muslim teachers mallah and
here the teachers in instead of coming
for five days they have to come six days
a week five days to teach our children
our school works from Monday to Thursday
and on Saturday we have Friday and
Sunday holidays which was very difficult
everyone objected initially that how is
this unconventional Friday and Sunday no
way do we have in the world I said we
have it in
I and mashallah in the long run it was
beneficial now the children are fresh to
study twice a week on Saturday and
Monday in the normal school they're
fresh only on Monday here they're fr
fresh twice a week on Saturday as well
as Monday and in our school we have got
no homework whatever start is Tau in the
school if there are some children who
take late Admissions and if they have
missed on the Arabic they have to come
on Sundays extras from 8 to 1 every
Sunday to catch up absolutely free and
our teachers they come five days to
teach from Monday to Thursday and
Saturday and on Friday they come to be
taught we educate our educators in our
school our
teachers they get training once a week
they have the best of professionals
coming to train them these professionals
they are very well qualified in the
field they may be psychologists they may
be psychiatrists they may be child
counselors they may be nutritious top
people Indian foreigners there will be
people top non-muslims we pay them
through the noses we have workshops on
Fridays and we train the teachers even
in voice and accent the voice and accent
training we give we spend lacks of
rupees so that they have a neutral
accent and in Bombay channel in a
non-muslim news channel it came the only
school which has voice and accent from
Junior classes
IIs so the specialized non-muslim
trainers come and train our teachers
they in turn train the students so our
teachers also mallah they have to work
hard we pay them but they work hard and
we are very strict with our rules
mashallah and we believe in
professionalism so what happened that by
the time they stay in our school they
get trained same thing with aari same
thing with Arabic gen teachers same
thing with Lady teachers and unless we
are professional in our field we will
not get the results and if we see the
annual day that we had the annual day
and we have shown that annual day even
on satellite channel moment we show on
the satellite channel the annual day of
our children performing we got
applications from different parts of the
world that we too want to open a similar
School
now just a few months back we had
another annual day which the cassette
has been released it is 10 times better
than the first one and alhamdulillah
there if you analyze it was for 5 hours
and only the children performed no adult
no teacher even spoke a word all the
children from Nursery to standard
five they performed and even they
themselves were the compare they
compared the program professionally Mah
they the compar they handled everything
not a single teacher even spoke a word
no one spoke for 5 hours without a break
the audience was glued to the seat glued
5 hours imagine our children from the
age of 3 and a half to 11 and a half
they glued the audience for 5 hours
mashallah and what we did we did not
spend a great deal of time we hardly
trained them for three to four weeks
that's it and in the first week it was 2
hours a day second week was 3 hours a
day
then half a day last week was 34 day so
they lost about two weeks of the school
on an average nine working days but we
saw to it that we got professionals we
had professional
choreographers whatever Islamic step
that we are taken and when we had the
show we had a dawa conference an
international dawa conference where our
students
mashah as I mentioned earlier the dawa
conference was started by the recitation
of sh sudesh so one of the students
dressed up by sh sudesh then we had Dr
is Ahmed giving a speech in U then we
had Bal Phillips coming then other
speakers brother ABD green Then There
are a person like shik Ahmed dad then my
son dressed up like Dr zakin Nik the
point to be noted was that we had
professional people to make up from the
film industry and the person who had
done if you know about Amita bachan who
had done the beard for Amita bachan in
Shen sha you know Shen sha though we
don't encourage people seeing movies but
I was told that the person who did the
beard for amab ban in Shen sha he was a
Muslim he happened to be my friend so we
hadir them mashallah and the makeup if
you see I doubt you might have seen
anywhere else that young children of the
age of 10 years 11 years the way they
performed and my son he copied the
speech five minute section of my speech
which I gave in London last year when
had come in December for the global
Unity of Peace the talk I gave at the
Excel theater and M you see same type of
beard same cap same coat the actions so
the teachers trained them the gestures
the way they walk the way they come the
mic the way they adjust the microphone
everything similarly with all the other
speakers if the speaker sits and speak
our children also sat and spoke and
there were various skits so if you see
the drama if you see the full five hour
you find children right from the age of
3 and a half to about 11 and half
performing and there's one section where
a person speaking the various languages
we teach in our school
English Arabic marati Hindi uru you
could see in the skit that our children
Mah so fluent in all the languages that
really impresses the people but one
thing you realize that we should believe
in professionalism and if you see in our
school we have all types of Muslim
taking admission Hani Shafi whether be
salafi
Islam but we say in our school we follow
Quran and
Sunnah and we take in right
that we will teach what is mentioned in
Quran and had and we make it very clear
we do not believe in dividing Muslims
into different sects Islam is against
that Quran is against that Quran says in
Surah Anam chapter 6 verse number 159
that if anyone makes sex of Islam it is
Haram oh prophet of Allah we have
nothing to do with him so in spite of
this we have the children of the heads
of the different jamaats jamat islamiat
all wanting admission Mah so you really
feel and you see a cross-section of the
Muslim um the rich class the middle
class the poor class the different
people and people come from far away
areas where they even have to travel two
and a half hours they come from length
and breadth of Bombay the school is in
Center Bombay people come from Mira Road
from mumra they travel two and a half
hours up 2 and half hours down and some
of the parents when the child is very
young they have to travel8 hours 2 hours
up and down to drop two hours up and
down to pick up so here find that once
you give quality people are bound to
come to you one thing is the Muslim umah
wants Islamic education but I believe me
I would not put my son in any of the
Muslim schools in Bombay if my school
wasn't
there not that I hate Muslims I like
them but I want my child to get proper
education the only option I had was to
start a
school so here we realize that there
should be demand and whatever activity
we do we always say there should be 10
times minimum more number of people
wanting to take part than the number of
seats you
have always if there's a demand then
mashallah you can provide quality and
you can get the best out of the people
because they know they have got
admission out of a great difficulty so
what we say they follow if you get easy
if it's a walkth through then they take
it for granted and to have this model
somewhere else there are many people who
copied all our syllabuses absolutely
anyone can copy it free no problem but
many people copied hardly anyone came
even close to 5% of what we are doing
the main thing is not the syllabus main
thing is the
management copying the syllabus is very
easy you can't take a syllabus from a
good American or a British school and
think you can match it main thing is how
well you control it how well you handle
it the management is very important the
management the teachers the parents all
put together there should be a
combination of everything everyone have
faith in each other then only will you
really be able to make a difference and
once you have the confidence of the
parents inshallah you can do
wonders so many times we introduce many
things masallah always there has been
cooperation so unless you don't have
quality you will not be able to achieve
what you're opting for and this is the
principle of Islam too that you believe
in quality anything we do so inshallah
what we want that our next Generation
that they should have that love with
Allah's so Mah if the Arabic is strong
unlike us if the Arabic is strong they
can understand the Quran directly they
can Implement on the message and they
can educate the
others keeping this in mind mashallah we
started the school and with Allah's help
alhamdulillah we never imagined that we
could achieve whatever we have achieved
it basically Allah's help whatever we
doing in irf in Bombay when we look back
we could not have dreamed of doing these
things and the best example is myself
during childhood I used to
stammer and I was in Medical College I
could have thought of becoming the best
doctor in my dream in your dream you can
dream of anything no one can stop you
but even in my dream I could not have
dreamed of speaking in front of 25
people because I was a stamer if you
would ask me what is your name my name
is Imagine Allah subhana wa ta'ala which
is
help what he has transformed in me it's
a
now I speak in front of 10 and 20,000
people 100,000 people largest audience
have addressed live is 1 million live
not on television live 1
million and in India mallah audien is
always 40,000 50,000 and the way we
manage on time we have 500 to 1,000
volunteers are
volunteers and when you call a guest
speaker there you see that when Dr is
Ahmed was called not a single volunteer
even shook hands with Dr isar Ahmed not
that they didn't like him they are
trained they trained that
mujahid they can't shift away from the
duty they have to do their Duty and then
only we get result everyone we have got
volunteers doctors Engineers M more than
a thousand volunteers we have in Bombay
so whatever we do we do professionally
that's the reason in our audiences more
than 25% are non-muslims more than
25% when we have 40,000 audience more
than 10,000 are non-muslim more than
what Muslims can gather here we have
non-muslims there coming for our talks
even on satellite mashallah there's a
great percentage of non-muslims watching
our programs and they appreciate
masallah so I would like to leave the
throat open for the question session I
would like to end this talk of educating
the Educators which was the main theme
of this conference and I chose Harrow
though I'm giving talks on every venue
different talks I don't believe in giv
the same talk every time so I chose this
when you harrowed the main theme educate
the educator and Harrow and we leave the
Thro open for the question session I
would like to end my talk with the
question of the Glorious Quran from
Surah is chapter 17 verse 81 where Allah
says when is in falsehood falsehood
perishes for falsehood is by nature B to
perish